today on our show he's the king of his
castle Frank Castle that is we released
one thank you we're gonna look at the
punisher trailer we're gonna watch it
[ __ ] twice you're gonna watch us
watch it like the dirty cups you are
today on fat man on Batman
Batman on Batman welcome the fat man now
Batman I'm Kevin's son Mark Barnard I'll
be honest with you I've seen this
trailer 800 times it's amazing it's
fantastic
it is the trailer for the Marvel Netflix
series forthcoming of the Punisher you
know indeed I'm agreeing all heartedly
with you thank you that's why were
friends Kevin Smith here and mr. mark
Bernard insane yes we're just here to
prove each other sentences who wouldn't
approve this everybody [ __ ] likes
this trailer man you know why this is
less before we dive into it I'm sure
this series gonna be wonderful
who's do we know who the creative team
is this time I don't know the creative
team is this certainly not the folks
behind iron fist in the know this seems
to have a little pulse to it a little
life to it a little metal to well and I
was just saying that because there's no
way that person could be working on
those series and the Punisher these were
happening kind of simultaneous yes I was
going out of value scale this looks
great no doubt but this here I'm sure it
looks fantastic
kudos and a big fat blow job end or you
know good trip oral [ __ ] licking [ __ ]
looking good
to whoever cut this trailer they are the
true artists now I know a lot of people
be like come on the people have person
not footage to cut with I don't give a
[ __ ] it takes a genius to be like I'm
gonna cut the guns to the drums in one
one and and and you know what it's
Netflix they'll pay for it yes and they
did look Kevin let me just say little
something here I am a single I have seen
in my day some metal [ __ ] this my friend
is the middle of [ __ ] I've ever seen
back to the 2-shot yeah in Lion our job
is to support one another and he's right
this is some endless [ __ ] I've ever seen
in my life every trailer needs to be
covered you know how you know remember
back in the 80s and maybe
more the 80s every trailer had yeah yes
they need to put Metallica every comedy
you've ever seen if you remake Benjy and
it doesn't have [ __ ] like darkness
has taken my I'm not taking my I'm [ __ ]
you I'm not going to see that dog move
this fall well Jennifer Anderson get to
really be happy with Colin Firth
darkness imprisoning I don't wayward
youth it is it's fantastic it's a
splendid cut of a trailer whoever did it
they ought to give credits really you
know an mtv this for the credits of the
who made the video and sooner or later
they added the directors yeah they ought
to add on the trailer cutters that they
would have rockstar followings because
hey man how many times you've seen a
[ __ ] trailer way better than the
movie you eventually see [ __ ] Yoko's
trailer felt that way to me
I loved that trailer I like that movie
still I'm just saying in the hands of a
[ __ ] you know artist turn it into
something I mean what that is in a way
how we get the Suicide Squad movie we
got because they cut a trailer that was
so amazing yeah they were like hey you
guys why don't you cut the movie
somewhere David Ayer is going like how
again with this Wow let it go he's not a
guy that's gonna be way pro marketing
and understandably but this I think even
David would get beyond this trailers
yeah [ __ ] fantastic so forever cut it
man kudos to you to you lady or man
you would have to kudos that being said
yeah man they're small that being said
let's dive into it shall we let's watch
it together you watch us watch it
yeah and I'm watched it and I would say
I've 12 hours yeah I've seen it only
twice yeah man met twice was when I
first dropped so yeah it's been a while
listen to you years in the linger it's
well personal to us like when it dropped
when it dropped him so weak I can't open
one hand get that fingers I feel like
Richard Dreyfuss when he crumples the
paper come to Joe okay deep cuts
reference okay man what we got here
ladies and gentlemen is we got the
Marvel's The Punisher Netflix trailer
official trailer ready to go it's 2
minutes and 27 seconds we're gonna watch
it or as Mark says drop it right now I'm
gonna turn the volume up you drop it
like it's hot
and we're gonna watch this [ __ ] right
now in the count of want watch they'll
put the OVA graphic on the screen one
but you can help capture always come
down yeah 3 3 2 1 watch how [ __ ] dark
this visual is dude like right away I'm
watching this I'm gone like I have
course he thinks bass family a lot yeah
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] dark right here
yeah nope
oh come on
holy the [ __ ] man like you can't get
away with that on network television I
did to cap it a pretty girls dome I
don't even know that HBO would do that
this is you've got my attention
oh but you know what's smart to do cuz
right off the bat you're like these
origin story done it earns them the
listing all those cousins
I come the little come on dude and the
shot of him in the shirt Baron thought
god [ __ ] you can't protect you Rick
and that's a dude from how Hartley
movies I know him I'm gonna get his name
I love him as an actor I'm sure he's
been a lot of things do you think that
micro micro yeah I thought microchip
supposed to be heavy guy the original
man in the chair whoosh look at that
little die hard down the hall I'm down
the [ __ ] staircase I hope you're
right I hope that is microchip family
holy [ __ ] your knees that ain't do that
[ __ ] oh my god dude oh my god
it is breathtakingly good yes right in
the head nope just doming [ __ ]
all day long I'm telling you Matt I
don't know if I could pay higher
compliment
maybe it's dangerous compliment to pay
but I that makes me want to buy a gun oh
my god oh my god what a commercial for
the NRA that is pretty much beside
everything else man but it's just like
how do I live this long without having a
gun a gun that I could shoot in sync to
the music - yeah this is this is like I
mean I mean it's borderline
irresponsible but it is kind of like
when they used to let Fred Flintstone
smoke cigarettes in those commercials
you just suddenly like or any movie star
smoke cigarettes then you're like so how
looks cool
yes I mean holy [ __ ] I mean I only want
to have sex because I won't have any
half
6x cigarette because that looks like a
bath do you know who we need to thank
for this some people I know people think
this this is not criticism this is true
praise the gamer culture is why we get a
trailer that [ __ ] good the gamer
culture be honest with you is why we got
in a sequence in Batman V Superman where
Batman came through a [ __ ] floor and
took out 20 dudes that looked as cool as
it did man because the folks in the
gaming world have pregame doll this [ __ ]
and shown us what these things look like
so that [ __ ] sequence man where he's
black like that looks like a a
first-person shooter game and a cutscene
from it yeah it also harkens back to
like the John Woo of like Vimeo my
credits the games and you're like hey
filmmaker maybe John Woo did this back
in the late 80s right stuff like hard
boy than the killer where she's walking
through a warehouse just killing
everybody and doing it in a very like
system man like this is how you do this
here I'm clearing a room like ifs and if
this I'm like I ain't glorifying it man
cuz if it happened to me in real life I
was the person they're receiving and
he's gonna file he was like get behind
me and he was just doing that blowing
people's knees off and then blowing
their faces off and then turning around
blowing another dudes face off I you
know we're the guys to stay back I don't
know if we get any shooting done because
that's what I would sound like but that
I'm telling you that looks [ __ ] cool
in the show I hope it never happens to
be in real life but that's what this
shit's for I mean it's also it's a bit
of John wick like John wick had a lot of
that like gun foo they called it of just
like a [ __ ] yeah yeah every once
in a while I think I'm clever but I'm
not whoever came up with gun foo there's
another one I heard the other day
Hollywood Reporter I think coined the
term R equal combination of the reboot
and the C it's not bad pretty [ __ ]
good man it was Santa's low-hanging
fruit nobody took it but gum gun foo is
awesome what a great turns [ __ ]
just moving through space
like the gun is an extension of the body
you've got my money for that I love that
I mean I'm I know I'm like I'm an easy
mark but [ __ ] especially because it
says the Punisher for the first time in
history looks and plays like The
Punisher I sent that to my boy Walt
Flanagan
from comic book man
because I was like you will never
believe the combination of [ __ ]
visuals a character we love and [ __ ]
Metallica not and he wrote back he's
like it's it's fantastic he goes it's
just so surprising it took them this
long to get a concept this easy this
right and it's true when you think back
over the history like the Dolph Lundgren
even the two cinematic versions honestly
I know a lot of people like [ __ ] you but
the closest that that character ever got
sent for me was the Lexi Alexander yes
war zone war zone was like brutal or
Journal or war zone war zone [ __ ] that
movie like that I was like and his
performance that dude from Yuri
Stephenson yeah like you know I liked
what's his [ __ ] the dude you know who
played him in the movies before what was
sound was Jane wonderful and was there
anybody else stuff long good sweet
dolefully
so Thomas Jane you know what Thomas
James got a lot of personality mm-hmm
and I'm not saying Ray Stevenson doesn't
erase Stephenson since he wasn't like
famous
he's like a Zen master and there was no
like oh you got to please the Ray
Stevenson audience so you got to do all
that Ray Stevens and stuff she was able
to play that guy as scripted as just
like I'm just a [ __ ] sold dead I
didn't kill him she's just punching the
clock on earth taking [ __ ] the dirt
out until he dies right I mean every day
is throwing himself into [ __ ] the
harm's way I mean the tricky part of the
punch actors are just as well is that is
that you know the Punisher is a
character like I'm always a fan of this
character when he's not a person that I
need to know how he got to be how he is
and is going to have an arc out of who
he is right the Punishers of weather
system he is a he's a hurricane that
lands in your [ __ ] apartment and
destroys everything yeah I mean I like
humanizing this person is almost a
mistake to me don't play it that way and
I'm really curious to know how you build
a like an 8 episode ten episodes 13
episodes show [ __ ] that how do you build
multiple seasons yeah cuz you want to
keep it going yeah I hope they keep them
like I did but it's like Batman like I
don't think that might one problem with
Dark Knight Rises well there's a few
problems but my biggest problem is
Batman never
tires Batman doesn't give up on God in
the books in real life you mean in
realize no real life he's a fictional
[ __ ] character mark there's always a
Batman it must be a Batman but you're
right he don't retire in that movie they
were like okay so I T can be happy in
Italy with the cappuccino and Catwoman
yeah but like and so in this like the
Punisher is mentally ill for certain is
there a cure is there a path for
treatment for this guy I don't want it
yeah what the putter should have you
know that's irresponsible to say but
you're right for this character it's
fictional character he don't need to be
an example there's so many [ __ ]
superheroes that kids could look at and
learn from and [ __ ] like that model
their lives after like this needs to be
exactly what this is this looks
phenomenal
he's the boogeyman and the boogeyman
shouldn't be redeemed at the end of it
otherwise he doesn't serve his purpose
which is to frighten the [ __ ] out of
criminals yeah like he's the criminal
boogeyman mmhmm yeah bring me that [ __ ]
this [ __ ] everything else there's lots
of this I want [ __ ] three helpings of
this man I'll pay for it I mean it would
be one season to have minutes I'd owe
and yet they didn't even tell us when
the things starting there's no release
date been released yet I know there was
there somebody they could drop it
whenever they wanted to drop it like my
guess is is probably close to done if
not done so they could they could be a
dick and just be like hey you know what
Justice League weekend have a Punisher
Wow that's coming up November yeah they
could absolutely do that let's see it's
such a Marvel movie it really would like
you'd get the one-two punch of Thor
Ragnarok and the Punisher and everyone's
always like now it's just circumstance
like it's just it's just it's not
intentional it's just an accident
somebody somewhere is going like there
you go let's see what they do
should we enact the Punisher protocol
why yes OOP release I'm watching this
all of it watching you fast like Bing
Bing Bing Bing watching 10 hours [ __ ]
I'm binging this hard man look I binge
defenders as much as I could like I had
to at one point I had to go to work I
was making superheroes so I had a job
but this I'm setting aside everything
and just sitting there for 10 hours
watching this [ __ ] watching gun porn
that was again you're responsible say I
know but and I'm not advocating [ __ ]
you know gun usage it but in my
fictional character the Punisher
yes I'm advocating gun use the same way
that I advocacy advocate [ __ ] shield
use in Captain America in the same way
that I advocate hammer usage in Thor so
please don't make it a political thing
let me enjoy my [ __ ] Punisher why do
I have so many disclaimer all of these
are just tools in the hands of the right
and/or the wrong people same way that i
lucking all for batman having batarangs
mm-hmm i want this guy to [ __ ] take
out the garbage [ __ ] I love this
character yes bring it faster Bharath
all crushing up man
you can't protect Rick you can't hurt
eject
Rick makes you forget this makes you
forget Shane
I've almost already forgotten Shane
anyway okay coming soon
yeah is our view of the trailer that's
it for this week I'm fat man I'm Batman
I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark barnard we're
gonna watch it twice before you watch on
your own you got the power come on man
all right
tune in next episode saying same fat
[ __ ] youtube.com slash Kevin Smith and
and I can't do the rest of those we got
closed
[Music]
[Applause]
you